I have a interesting documentary to
recommend to you today it is a
documentary called the vasectomy and it
follows I call him an eccentric and
quirky doctor who travels the world his
mission this is dr. Doug Stein his
mission is to just continue doing the
SEC Tamizh and he's motivated by
population control because of climate
change and limited resources on earth so
duck dr. Doug Stein who does vasectomies
a believes that we are rapidly barreling
towards an unsustainable situation on
earth with regard to resource
consumption population and the way that
this will impact our environment so he
travels the world all over the place in
the u.s. he drives around in this old
minivan that you see in the documentary
he goes all over the world doing the
sect amis and he's reportedly done
something like 25,000 vasectomies at
this point I believe uh 30,000
vasectomies it's it's a pretty big
number he's a quirky guy and part of the
the fascinating thing about the film is
the way in which in many countries route
best vasectomy is incredibly
controversial in religious countries
vasectomy is hugely controversial that's
interesting the other interesting
element of this documentary is that dr.
Stein is just incredibly peculiar and
quirky and that's interesting to see the
one thing i don't like about the
documentary is when vasectomies are done
there's a particular snapping noise that
to most people with male genitals is not
a noise you want to hear coming from
that area and uh just be prepared for
that if you're going to check out the
documentary it is called the vasectomy
stand you can see all of my
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations